Google is working on project loon and
Google Fiber what do you think of
Google's approach to connecting the
world well the thing is connecting
everyone is going to be something that
no single company can do by themselves
so I'm really glad that they and a lot
of other companies are working on this
internet org is a partnership between a
number of different technology companies
and nonprofits and governments and there
are folks who are doing things that
they're contributing to internet org
there are companies that are doing
things that are separate that's gonna be
necessary right there's a lot of
technology that's gonna need to be
developed in order to build in order to
tackle all three of those major barriers
that I talked about no technical making
it so that everyone has a network near
them affordability so that way the
network is efficient and social making
it so that people have the content that
they need in order to want to get online
and consume all this so I'm very
positive on it have you had any talks
with Google about potentially partnering
with them would you ever partner with
Google yeah I mean our team is in
contact with them frequently and I
talked to a number of folks over there
when we launched in Zambia and Google
was actually one of the services that
was in the internet org suite and that's
valuable right because in addition to
health services and education and jobs
and different government services and
communication tools people need to be
able to search and find information and
you know whether we work with Google on
that or others and all these other
countries I think that's an important
thing and I'd love to work with Google
they're a great search product